à l'abitibi témiscamingue
le pays des forestières et des minières
surtout les mines d'or de très grosses
même d'ordre
mais attention on parle de plus en plus
de lithium un métal utilisé dans la
fabrication des batteries des véhicules
électriques est pas mal tous nos gadgets
électroniques nous annonce que le
gouvernement a l'intention d'extraire
ces gisements ou créer plus de richesse
ici
nos gouvernements poussent fort pour
attirer les investissements vers
l'exploitation des différents minéraux
nécessaires à la transition énergétique
comme les visions
la stratégie semble bien fonctionner en
l'abitibi la ruée vers l'or blanc déjà
commencé
[Musique]
l'abitibi c'est une immense plaine
pourtant quand tu arrives pas loin d'une
mine il ya des montagnes des montagnes
de déchets miniers
ici celle de la mine north american
lithium à la corne la mine est fermée
depuis quelques années son ancien
propriétaire a causé des déversements et
a connu des ennuis financiers
la mienne vient tout juste d'être vendue
à une entreprise australienne saiosn à
mining
le nouveau pdg nous reçoit pour nous
expliquer comment il peut relancer la
mine et du cradat dans mon test de ces
frais il fait à peu près moins 1000 moi
je rêve du jour où je veux voir dans une
tesla ou un autre véhicule électrique
dilithium de l'abitibi vendu à un
américain de new york qui va brancher
tous les soirs sur véhicules électriques
avec de l'électricité qui vient du
québec pour lesquelles on a vous et moi
on en redemande alors ça c'est le bon
attendant
on parle des sites de la création d'une
nouvelle industrie on se rappelle il ya
20 heures 25 ans oui a eu une lancée de
construction d'aluminé ok avec ça fait
un peu penser à ça
aujourd'hui sillonnant développe trois
projets de mines de lithium en abitibi
la mine de la cornée la plus avancée
iraient juste à relancer les opérations
deux autres mines sont projetées l'une
et en prospection l'autre fera l'objet
d'audiences devant le bape en 2022
la minière dit détenir assez de lithium
pour construire les batteries de 48
millions de voitures électriques
la chance que l'on au québec de faire
ces produits la première avec une
énergie verte dans une réglementation
une législation très stricte au niveau
de l'environnement et avec des sarts
action hautement compétitif est alors
question qu'on se pose est ce que vous
préférez que votre batterie vial de
chaîne ou si on veut structurer cette
pollution la pile le faire le québec
c'est impressionnant mettre au fond
d'une fosse pour la première fois on se
sent minuscule
on est d'or mais pas vraiment en nature
on
on est dans le ventre de l'industrie
à quelque part ça fait réaliser le coût
réel du téléphone dans nos poches
[Musique]
se terminer les projets miniers comme il
ya cinquante ans on est dans une heure
de plus grande intégration de la
communauté dans les projets de les
employés
sont tous des parents eux aussi veulent
faire bien les choses voici une autre
opportunité
verte qui nous amène à améliorer les
conditions de vie de nos les notes est
plutôt celle de nos petits enfants
[Musique]
rodrick turgeon un avocat de val-d'or
pense lui aussi aux enfants de l'abitibi
on comprend vite amoureux de sa région
natale et qu il veut la protéger à tout
prix du commun conception d'abitibi dans
l'imaginaire populaire que on est une
région sauvage quasi inexploité alors
que c'est tout le contraire leur mrc
d'abitibi lautour d'amos jusqu'à 1.5 %
de son territoire de protéger c'est
parmi les plus beaux tôt au québec il
rêve de sauver le territoire où ils nous
emmènent d'en faire une aire protégée
c'est ici que ça you know my name veut
développer son deuxième projet le projet
outils
on grandit avec cette relation n'a
particulière avec la nature en abitibi
[Musique]
on est très attaché à la nature mais
c'est une relation qui est voué à être
explosé tuant dynamiter
à disparaître un certain point
[Musique]
ou apprendre à aimer
mais on voudrait que l'on nous offre des
opportunités
d'amour durable réellement ces deux
territoires dans nature
avec mes enfants
[Musique]
faux
c'est l'éventualité d'une mine à ciel
ouvert ici ça va être explosé qui aura
plus de villes ça va être un trou puis
ils vont une montagne de déchets miniers
et ici ça va être
on explose on met ça dans des camions on
chez psion à la 70e kilomètre
transformation on chip soit d'étrangers
merci bonsoir tesla compagnie seul plein
le projet authier a beaucoup fait jaser
c'est assez rare en abitibi de voir une
telle mobilisation contre un projet
minier on craint que la mine détruisent
un joyau de la région sont nous la mine
serait situé juste à côté de lescar
saint mathieu bélie 1 et ce car c'est
une formation géologique ça agit comme
un filtre pour l'eau souterraine dans ce
cas si elle est devenue célèbre
c'est la source de l'eau eska et elle a
remporté des prix à l'international pour
sa pureté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui est sur la table c'est un projet
de kilomètres de long par 600 m de large
par peu près 300 mètres de profond
c'est une mine à ciel ouvert c'est une
force ce qui frappe avec le projet outil
c'est la proximité en la fosse le trou
et l'escarcelle du be2 creusant un trou
comme ça d'un seul ça crée une zone de
rabattement les eaux souterraines aux
attentes au renvoi tendance à vouloir
venir rang combler le trou a été creusé
puis ça ça la seiche des milieux et des
rivières des lacs de surface autour
le gisement de lithium il s'enfonce ou
lescar donc s'ils veulent agrandir la
fosse et non seulement ils s'aligneront
pas de l'escale ils vont suivre le
gisement saiosn à manning affirme que
son projet ne représente aucun risque
pour lescar elle assure qu elle le
prouvera hors de tous deux devant le
bureau d'audiences publiques sur
l'environnement quelque part en 2022 de
son côté
comité de protection de l'espierre
demande d audience sur toutes les
activités de la minière australienne pas
seulement sur le projet routier
finalement c'est ce grand projet là dont
il est question pour juste une mine à
ciel ouvert ici le
depuis les dernières années ils ont
racheté une mine à la corde puis ils
veulent partir un autre projet au
témiscamingue leurs proches leur méga
projet a changé les évaluations
devraient refléter cette ce changement
[Musique]
rodrigues sur gens viennent parler du
troisième projet du cio nous dans la
région direction du témiscamingue vers
le projet tanger
[Musique]
dans la communauté anishinabe de
winneway on parle beaucoup de saion à
manille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les concessions de sai ona qui bordent
le lac simard inquiet la minière a
annoncé son intention d'y développer une
autre mine à ciel ouvert encore une fois
le minerai serait envoyé à la corde la
mine se trouverait en plein coeur du
territoire n'ont cédé de la communauté
de l'ong points c'est là qu'on retrouve
son chef steve matyas chez nous on va
dire dans notre culture si que la terre
ne nous appartient pas on est les
gardiens de la terre et si c'est le rôle
qu'on a à jouer pour faire face à ces
gros enjeux climatiques et ses
sacrifices qu'on a affaire au sein de
notre communauté de conserver des
territoires vierges ou un tac
on voit laisser croire à nos jeunes à
nos petits-enfants 12
arrière-petits-enfants
on a le privilège dans ma génération que
nos ans appuyé nos aînés qui ont jamais
assez des territoires puis qu'ils ont t
ils ont toujours à ses deux protégés de
le mieux qu'ils peuvent
c'est sûr que nous autres on veut faire
pour les autres générations si à l'école
du village une enseignante a décidé de
se lancer en politique
pour elle le projet taz émetteurs risque
pour la culture anishnabe
[Musique]
m
thomas
[Musique]
le gouvernement du québec investit
énormément dans l'extraction des
minéraux stratégiques que ce soit par
des participations financières dans des
compagnies des subventions et des
campagnes de publicité mais au final en
abitibi près de 95 % des redevances
versées au gouvernement proviennent de
minières qui ne sont pas dans les
méthodes à venir c'est le cas de l'or
qui sert en majorité à l'industrie
financière
et ça c'est la plus grande mine d'or à
ciel ouvert au canada
la fosse s'étend sur près de deux
kilomètres et les tellement profondes
qu'on pourrait y entrer la tour eiffel
c'est ici qu'on rencontre hugo lapointe
un consultant dans le monde minier et
environnementalistes le gouvernement ne
rêve pas seulement de lithium mais bien
d'une dizaine de minéraux selon lui avec
cette nouvelle kate ce paysage d'abitibi
se multipliera au sud de la province
actuellement il ya une compagnie
s'appelle nouveau monde graphique qui
propose le projet dans le secteur
de saint michel des saints au nord de
montréal il propose une mine de 2.7 km
de long de force à ses nouvelles mais ça
ressemble à ça
concrètement ça ressemble ceci dit il y
en faut des mines parce que on a des
métaux on les utilise il faut vraiment
être soucieux de nos choix de société et
nos choix de consommation
vous savez si demain on doit faire plus
d'extraction de lithium de graphite pour
du transport électrique
mais peut-être qu'on peut revisiter
revoir nos extraction de dons métaux
minéraux par exemple l'or est ce qu'on a
vraiment besoin de l'en au québec 2000
sur trois sont des mines doivent
actuellement c'est ça la réalité il sait
90 % pour l'industrie de la joaillerie
et les banques qui les réserves
bancaires
c'est pas vrai de dire que les miennes
d'abitibi sont ouvertes parce qu'il ya
trop projet de lithium qui sont à venir
des dix prochaines années le
gouvernement lui-même aux listes et des
minéraux critique et stratégies qui vont
pouvoir aider notamment dans la lutte
contre la crise climatique et il faut
qu'on se dirige vers ce que fait-on des
mines qui ne sont ni critique des
stratégies
que tu fais ton des minéraux qu'ils ne
sont ni ce qui se dit stratégiques sont
pas dans la liste du gouvernement pour
lutter contre la crise climatique dont
l'or au projet mais je pense que quand
même discours d'écoblanchiment 1 qui se
fait au dos de l'industrie des minéraux
critique et stratégiques soudainement
les mines sont vertes parce que on veut
alimenter les voitures électriques en
présente l'instru miens comme une
solution verte au changement climatique
alors que c'est pour le corps c'est pas
une solution verte il faut en faire des
mines de lithium il faut le faire
intelligemment il faut le faire avec des
politiques publiques où on va d'abord
prioriser une réduction à la source une
réduction de la consommation mettent en
place des politiques
oui de véhicules zéro émission mais
aussi de réduction de la taille du parc
automobile mettre autant d'argent dans
le recyclage et l'économie circulaire
que dans l'exploration minière immeuble
actuellement on met des pinottes dans le
recyclage de l'économie circulaire puis
on met des centaines de millions dans
l'extraction des matières vierge
remplacer six millions de véhicules à
essence au québec par 6 millions de
véhicules électriques oui on va avoir
gagné au niveau de la réduction des gaz
à effet de serre mais on est toujours
dans une logique de l'extractivisme des
ressources parce qu'on a remplacé
l'extraction du pétrole de garde par de
l'extraction minière ce sens un coût
environnemental un coût social qui
pourrait négliger
en termes d'environnement c'est
indéniable que les minières ont un
impact
elio les montagnes de résidus miniers
des autres procédés contaminés et
l'énergie nécessaires pour le raffinage
certains camions miniers peuvent
consommer jusqu'à 250 litres de
carburant par heure et ce sont les
conséquences prévues pour les accidents
on a demandé au ministère de
l'environnement combien d'infractions
environnementales avaient été commises
par l'industrie minière au québec depuis
940 en moyenne une infraction
environnementale aux quatre jours depuis
plus de dix ans
[Musique]
on n'est pas contre le développement
mais on n'est pas prêt avant deux
territoires où nos ressources à
n'importe quel prix
si on veut ni médecin privé
au bénéfice d'une multinationale
et que c'est notre but est
de rester tête avec les dommages
subis
on n'est pas prête à faire ce sens de
sacrifice
[Musique]
on veut pas avoir des mines de nulle
part vous savez c'est facile de paul à
macau mais il faut faire faire valoir
les bénéfices et puis le temps et la
communication devrait résoudre ce
problème
si on veut placer sur le marché des
batteries fait dans des dattes de
d'excellentes conditions je pense que le
québec est bien placé pour contribuer
largement au niveau de la planète à la
lutte aux changements climatiques
toute la planète tous les gens on veut
faire une contribution pour la crise
climatique
la question que nous on a su poser c'est
est-ce que ça va être ça notre
contribution le reste la carte kids ou
gros bateaux tout seul ça marche ok on
continue on change de poste on se leurre
si on pense que l'abitibi la seule
contribution qu'on peut avoir c'est un
faune sans direction
on peut pas juste attendre que le
lithium sauve la planète
la voiture qu'elle soit thermique ou
qu'elles soient électriques il ya plein
de problèmes associés avec point de vue
environnemental et c'est un constat
d'échec avec l'argent que les québécois
m dans les véhicules individuels on
aurait de quoi se payer des systèmes de
transport collectif des trains à haute
vitesse pour couvrir le québec tenait à
10 ans avec on connaît des changements
climatiques parce qu'on va vraiment se
tourner vers damas continuer sur ce
système orienté sur les véhicules privés
de six ponts à votre voiture pour aller
s'acheter enfin de l'ovalie on peut pas
dire que le projet écologique
[Musique]